in a Green Beret mali's military Junta
leader simikoita seen as a foe by the
west but a hero to his supporters
in what seems to be a political campaign
goitai is calling on people to vote Yes
in a referendum to change the
Constitution he says it will bring peace
to Mali the new text would give greater
power to the president and more autonomy
to the regions it will also allow goita
to run for the presidency in next year's
elections I say yes to a cine goita our
next president I love our country and I
love the Armed Forces I think they're
doing a good job we want a new
constitution for young people in Mali it
will bring peace prosperity instability
but those calling for a no referendum
say the secular text insults the Muslim
majority country
it feels like they've trodden on the
Quran and disrespected our Prophet will
not keep quiet on this issue opposition
politician isakao Jim says the military
Junta is not credible to run this
referendum
the danger is that it sets a precedent
allowing any soldiers to take up arms
and orchestrate the coup then change the
Constitution and run for office it's
like we have returned to the 1970s
the current Constitution inherited from
France the former colonial power is
perceived as out of step with Malian
Society
campaign for this referendum most are
young women and men first-time voters it
is for them more than a referendum an
opportunity to have their say over the
country's future but away from the
capital bamako in the regions many
millions will not be able to take part
in the vote
the military has lost control of large
parts of the country to Armed groups
linked to Al-Qaeda and isil it blames
the U.N Mission and wants peacekeepers
out of the country but the UN is also
supporting this referendum delivering
ballot papers to remote areas with
malians finally having a say on how they
want to be governed Paving the way for a
return to democracy